[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans audition
publique l'émission en politique commune
à LCP Public Sénat une heure en invité
cette semaine
Eric Coquerel député LFI et président de
la commission des finances merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation bonsoir
Monsieur Coquerel au menu évidemment la
réforme des retraites après son examen
mouvementé à l'Assemblée nationale et
elle arrive au Sénat demain
qu'attendez-vous de cette étape Éric
Coquerel la gauche 100 et les filles
peut-elle retarder l'examen du texte
comme elle l'a fait au Palais Bourbon le
gouvernement serait prêt à stopper avec
la droite sur plusieurs amendements elle
sera au bénéfice des Français le 7 mars
large mobilisation syndicale en tout cas
les syndicats espèrent votre rêve est-il
de bloquer la France n'est-ce pas trop
tard avec Brigitte boucher nous vous
interrogerons sur cette bataille des
retraites Yves Thréard reviendra sur le
malaise aussi de LFI vous avez été
cartés de l'exécutif comme d'autres
d'ailleurs vous avez accepté de débattre
avec la sénatrice Renaissance violette
la député pardon violette spielbou merci
beaucoup ce sera tout à l'heure aux
alentours de 19h10
j'ajoute que vous êtes président à la
commission des finances évidemment vous
avez dissipé les craintes de ceux qui
voyaient
éventuellement le loup entrer dans la
bergerie quel bilan tirez-vous de
l'expérience en y reviendra et puis je
le signale pour le principe Éric
Coquerel sachant que l'écho donnés à une
accusation résonne toujours plus que
celui donné à une mise hors de cause et
c'est valable pour tout le monde quel
que soit l'étiquette politique vous avez
été mis hors de cause dans l'enquête
ouverte pour agression et harcèlement
sexuel c'est dit la réforme des
retraites Eric Coquerel les milliers
d'amendements n'ont pas permis aux
députés d'examiner tous les articles et
procédés à un vote sur le texte de
général un assemblée s'est il y a une
bonne huitaine de jours est-ce que le
Parlement n'est pas davantage fait
davantage fait pour débattre que pour
bloquer
le Parlement n'est pas fait pour qu'on
passe un projet sur les retraites donc
chacun constatera qu'il est d'importance
pour les années à venir avec une loi qui
permet un projet de loi un outil
parlementaire le 47 ans le fameux projet
de loi de finance de la sécurité sociale
rectificative qui permet de le passer
avec un temps extrêmement limité de
débat qui permet de même de le passer
sans vote c'est quand même la négation
même de ce que devrait faire des
parlementaires alors on a eu les
différents
a choisi cette procédure que vous
contestiez au départ ensuite le débat
arrive tel quel dans le calendrier
imposé est-ce que il était de c'était
une bonne stratégie d'empêcher le débat
d'aller jusqu'au bout alors déjà c'est
un cadre imposé mais que le gouvernement
pouvait modifier moi je n'ai pas arrêté
de le dire jusqu'au vendredi le
gouvernement avait tout à fait le loisir
il y a une décision du Conseil consuel
de 19 qui le dit très clairement de
prolonger le débat au-delà du vendredi
de finir de trois quatre jours
nécessaires pour finir le débat donc il
en est responsable tout comme d'ailleurs
je vous fais remarquer à l'avance il
aura la possibilité au bout de 50 jours
c'est à dire le 16 mars 2 poursuivre
aussi le débat rien n'empêche rien de le
contraint à rester dans ce calendrier
s'il le fait pourquoi le fait-il alors
est-ce qu'on peut parler de vous parce
que vos partenaires par exemple un
problème démocratie vous avez raison
vous avez raison et on interroge le
gouvernement quand on est face à lui sur
cette stratégie et effectivement il n'a
pas choisi de prolonger comme il aurait
pu le faire maintenant vous avez des
partenaires qui ont un peu tordu le nez
face à votre stratégie ils ont trouvé
que par exemple
Boris Vallot hier dans le Journal du
Dimanche vous l'avez lu depuis des
socialistes qui dit que effectivement la
nuque n'a pas montré son meilleur visage
pendant les débats dit-il nous devons
respecter notre cadre commun nous en
sommes sortis ça ne doit pas se
renouveler de quoi parle-t-il d'une
position commune qui avait été faite sur
le fait de pouvoir discuter de l'article
7 de pouvoir aller jusqu'à l'examen de
l'article 7 c'était une position commune
vous n'avez pas respecté ce cadre commun
donc c'est un débat quand même interne
vous êtes contesté sur cette stratégie
je vous interroge stratégie
je vous dis soit on regarde les
différents statiques parce que pour moi
elle était active de savoir si on allait
ou pas au début de l'article 7 soit on
regarde ce qui faisait accord entre nous
ce qui faisait accord entre nous de
toute la nuit Pesse c'était le fait
qu'il était hors de question d'aller
jusqu'à la fin de l'examen de la loi y
compris jusqu'à la fin de l'article 16
dans le cadre du calendrier qui nous
était imposé ça c'était un accord global
pourquoi parce que notre notre mission
notre rôle dans l'opposition
contrairement à ce qu'a fait le
rassemblement national qui a tout à fait
joué le jeu du gouvernement c'est pas de
permettre comme ça qu'on passe une loi
en vitesse aussi grammatiques que celle
du de retraite donc ça ça faisait accord
la différence était tactique moi je ne
suis pas sûr commune de l'intergroupe
c'était de débattre de débattre de
l'article 7 vous n'êtes pas arrivé à
l'article 3 positions
je vous rappelle par exemple que au
moment de l'article 2
le lundi puisque l'article 2 est examiné
la nupes y compris France insoumise a
retiré tous ses amendements pour pouvoir
accélérer est-ce que vous pensez que ça
ça accéléré sur l'article 2 et bien non
réponse la donne téléspectateurs qui
regardent pendant 24 heures on a
continué à discuter de l'article 2
uniquement sur les amendements de
renaissance et de la droite
est-ce que vous avez empêché
nous avons joué notre rôle de
parlementaire qui est que quand il y a
une loi de cette importance il est hors
de question la passer en quatrième
vitesse parce que le gouvernement a
décidé ainsi et de toute façon initiat
attendez pas sinon il aurait pas utilisé
cette procédure donc tout pour nous par
exemple sur l'article 3 enfin la
préarticle 2 je rentre dans une taille
mais qui était extrêmement important qui
était de montrer par exemple qui avait
des recettes hautes que de faire
d'obliger les gens à travailler deux ans
de plus nous avons estimé oui qu'il
fallait aller au fond du débat et aller
au fond du débat a permis par exemple de
révéler on en parlera après le le
comment dire quelque chose scandale des
1200 euros théoriquement
les les questions sur les carrières
en a rendu compte Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne
voulait pas qu'on arrive à la situation
qui permettait de voter l'article 7
et sur le projet
de loi toute la nuit pêche était
d'accord pour dire que il était hors de
question de faire ce cadeau gouvernement
d'adopter à la va-vite ce projet loi de
cette manière là qui le temps qu'il y
mettait qui était un parti donc la
différenciation elle était tactique et
si je vous dis ça c'est parce que je le
dis à Boris Vallot comme je le dis à
tous les interlocuteurs qui sont engagés
contre la femme de retraite ne jouons
pas le jeu du gouvernement c'est-à-dire
ne commençons pas à nous envoyer des
petites phrases qui à mon avis sont des
choses qui peuvent se discuter entre
nous moi j'ai aucun problème par rapport
à ça
la place publique des désaccords avec
nous ce qu'il faut s'arrête de mettre
sur la place publique des
différenciations tactiques que ce soit
entre nous et les syndicats dans la
nouvelle pourquoi parce que ce qui ne
permettra de gagner le projet de loi de
retraite c'est deux choses c'est le fait
que la grève à partir du 7 mars
fonctionne c'est à dire soit mis à
l'arrêt et c'est l'unité sans l'unité
syndicale qui est vraiment j'allais dire
le 13 or de cette grève il y a eu l'ont
très longtemps qu'on a pas vu des appels
qui vont de la CGT à la CFDT en passant
par la CFTC les ministres
l'unité de réalisation
je n'alimenterai pas cette machine à
petite phrase qui fait que sur des
questions je vous le dis je comprends
que ça vous fasse pas plaisir et moi je
vous dis pas c'est une question
principale
je dis une chose c'est que quel que soit
l'endroit où on situe et par rapport à
la bataille contre la réforme des
retraites contre cette réforme de
retraite je pense que il faut qu'on se
concentre sur l'objectif qui est que le
gouvernement c'est obligé de reculer et
donc l'objectif c'est pas entre nous
discuter à mon avis de manière
incessante de nos différents
et les autres mais maintenant je pense
qu'il faut que ça s'arrête et qu'on se
concentre sur le 7 donc vous regrettez
qu'il est dit ceci il n'est pas le seul
les insultes ont-elles leur place dans
le débat je leur regrette mais je ne lui
retiens pas rigueur
avec Boris Vallaud ça se passe très bien
l'assemblée et avec tous les députés de
la nups on a terminé le vendredi en
train d'applaudir tous Olivier fort qui
avait fait une intervention une fois de
plus pour dire qu'il fallait prolonger
le débat sans aucun problème l'unité
doit prévaloir jusqu'à la fin de la
bataille des retraites les désaccords
étalés dans le départ
les insultes ont-elles leur place dans
le débat
les insultes les insultes je crois pas
mais d'une certaine manière ce qu'on a
vu à l'Assemblée faut arrêter avec cette
histoire de propagande gouvernement on a
l'impression qu'on a vécu un chaudron
absolument historique c'est Monsieur
Debré l'ancien président de l'Assemblée
lui-même qui a dit que dans le passé ça
a été quand même beaucoup plus secoué
beaucoup plus dur que ça l'état y
compris
on a l'impression de repeindre
l'assemblée sauce prend sa soumise et
laisser penser que c'est inédit alors
je vais vous sortir des références très
étonné de déclaration je rappelais vous
qui a eu des on sait on s'est battus en
duel d'Off enfin suite à des débats dans
cet assemblée monsieur Jospin je regarde
encore des débats qui ont eu lieu il y a
quelques années de ça a été quasiment
pris à parti
mettons de dépeindre ça correspondait un
peu ce que voulait à coller monsieur
Darmanin communiste qui est pas un
perdreau de pardon il a il a une
ancienne thé parlementaire il en a vu
d'autres et bien lui il s'est senti
humilié on se rappelle de sa prise de
parole
votre confrère à traiter ce qui sortent
Olivier notre collègue qu'a-t-il fait
qu'a-t-il fait il a pris la parole pour
dire qu'il regrettait ce terme c'est
quand même assez rare pour un député et
je comptais j'écoutais Chassaigne
applaudit applaudi de manière importante
par la droite et Renaissance je voudrais
dire je voudrais lui dire à André quand
même que il devrait regarder ce qu'on
fait le Parti communiste dans les
décennies passées il s'apercevrait qu'à
certains moments les débats ont été
forts il y a des moments où les choses
vont trop loin les choses vont trop loin
mais
à part deux trois événements qui ont eu
lieu et qui ont été montés en exergue
parce que c'était un peu aussi le jeu
que vous voulez monter le gouvernement
sur cette question moi je trouve que les
débats vu l'ampleur de cette réforme et
l'attaque quelle qu'elle compte
l'attaque qui est celle de cette
rencontre les Français je trouve qu'on
est resté dans des normes finalement
assez assez
ce débat pour conclure vous n'avez pas
affaibli pardon le Parlement
c'est ceux qui nous impose dans 47 ans
et de discuter en 9 jours d'un projet de
réforme qui condamne les gens à vivre à
travailler deux ans de plus ça oui je
pense qu'ils a faiblissent le Parlement
bonjour Brigitte boucher bonsoir
journaliste à LCP c'est à vous oui je
voulais vous faire réagir à ces propos
de Patrick kaner le chef de fil
socialiste au Sénat qui a donné une
interview aux échos ce matin et qui et
qui dit que il veut examiner l'ensemble
du texte qui veut aussi aller à
l'article 7 et il revendique le fait
d'avoir déposé 10 fois moins
d'amendement est-ce que pour vous vous
dites la gauche finalement elle se
couche au Sénat non non je me dis pas ça
mais j'aurais juste vous signaler les
choses je pense qu'ils iront à l'article
7 et vous savez pourquoi ils iront parce
que le Sénat ouvre deux weekends de
suite pour le débat ce que a refusé de
faire la présence de l'Assemblée
parce que si vous regardez où on en
était le vendredi soir je pense que si
on avait eu trois jours de plus c'est à
dire qu'il correspondait à la niche que
le Parti socialiste acceptait de
reporter ce qui nous aurait fait gagner
une journée plus le week-end on avait
les trois jours nécessaires donc le
Sénat pour faire du Sénat une
intelligence le président du Sénat le
président du Sénat a eu l'intelligence
justement d'ouvrir les week-ends qui
modifie comme les choses que ça leur
donne deux jours de débat en plus plein
et entier et vous savez comme moi que
traditionnellement au Sénat mais ça
c'est vrai sur toutes les lois il y a
moins d'amendements c'est presque une
tradition d'abord en commission il est
vrai que uniquement les rapporteurs ont
droit de déposer des amendements donc ça
réduit la durée du débat voilà c'est une
autre façon de faire que que l'assemblée
mais moi je pense que le la gauche j'ai
cru le comprendre d'ailleurs sur le fond
va batailler va se battre vous
réjouissez du coup qu'elle puisse
examiner l'article 7 je me réjouis
qu'elle ait plus de jours que nous pour
pouvoir le faire
l'article 7 j'ai lu j'ai lu la de la
part de sénatrices communistes le fait
de dire que il se serait fort de ne pas
examiner l'article 7 avant le 7
a été fait exprès mais donc de le faire
pour pas justement un moment donné
envoyer un signal qui pourrait être vécu
comme négatif si l'article 7 était voté
donc j'ai lu ça nous on aurait eu je
vous le dis nous on aurait eu le nombre
de jours nécessaires et moi je l'ai
redemandé encore une fois je le disais
exactement qui me dit oui mais ça c'est
le gouvernement mais ça c'était
important moi j'ai redemande jusqu'au
bout qu'il dépasse la date fatidique de
minutes pour être jusqu'au bout donc on
aurait examiné l'article 7 et pourtant
regardez ce tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
tweet il y a quelques jours bravo les
groupes nubes du Sénat adoptent la
stratégie du groupe LFI à l'Assemblée
pour empêcher le vote de l'article 7
avant le blocage populaire du 7 mars
Patrick kaner a dénoncé l'ingérence vous
admettez une forme d'ingérence là
c'est un peu de nous quoi
exagère en parlant d'ingérence que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a été le candidat
enfin le candidat de la présidentielle
le mieux en tête à gauche qui a permis
que la nupaisse existe et permettent
ainsi à chacun d'avoir des groupes
importants à l'Assemblée nationale
disent ce qui à un moment donné ce qu'il
pense sur la stratégie au Sénat enfin
personne est empêché de parler sur tel
ou telle chose
quand même Jean-Luc Mélenchon Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous voulez pas examiner
l'article 7 parce qu'il avait peur que
si on était battu à l'article 7 ça
contre coup vis-à-vis du mouvement voilà
c'est un choix il l'a dit etc est-ce
qu'on peut parler pour autant
d'ingérence et moi ce que j'observe
encore une fois je vous le dis c'est que
le Sénat si j'ai bien compris ce sera
fort de ne pas examiner l'article 7
avant le que le 7 mars commence une
stratégie divergente en fait la
stratégie différente mais est-ce que
vous croyez c'est un petit peu la
réponse que j'ai fait les auteurs choux
est-ce que ça c'est très important
franchement j'ai bien compris
je vais aller au fait j'ai compris les
journaux comme vous etc et je vois que
alors qu'on prépare une grève générale
le 7 mars de tous les syndicats que le
gouvernement est quand même très dans
une grosse difficulté par rapport à
cette situation on discute de de des
problématiques de la LFI des pro
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec les
syndicats on discute de tout ça sauf de
ce qui fait le cœur de ce qui se passe
c'est à dire que il y a une unité
syndicale et que toute la nuit
évoquer les stratégies des
parlementaires moi ce qui me paraît plus
important je vais vous dire c'est que
toute la nuit pêche à l'Assemblée et au
Sénat tous les groupes tous les groupes
il y a aucun sénateur elle est fixe
qui composent la nups au Sénat et tous
les partis qui composent la nups c'est
la nuit
le plus important c'est que quel que
soit j'allais dire leur ancrage à gauche
ils sont tous pour le projet du le
retrait pur et simple du projet ils
soutiennent tous une grève de fête
générale une grève interprofessionnelle
le 7 à partir du 7 et croyez moi que
dans le passé par rapport à un projet de
retraite ça n'a pas toujours été comme
ça donc moi c'est ça que je regarde
avant tout c'est toujours une autre
unités
France insoumises ne sont pas syndiqués
ils ne se font pas se mobiliser vous
croyez que moi je ne vais pas faire du
tout je ne vais pas au Parlement est-ce
qu'il est pas est-ce qu'il est pas
terminé est-ce que vous avez pas perdu
le combat du Parlement non on a enfin de
toute façon nous n'étions a priori pas
majoritaire au Parlement mais on l'a pas
perdu ce combat le gouvernement n'a pas
pu passer son n'a pas pu faire voter son
projet de retraite comme il avait pas pu
faire voter son son budget alors ça si
ça paraît normal qu'un gouvernement qui
nous dit qu'il est légitime pour imposer
un projet de de revente soit obligé de
s'abriter derrière 47 ans pour passer en
force et finalement sans vote
excusez-moi mais j'ai pas l'impression
que nous perdons soit et les filles dans
l'histoire de façon c'est pas tellement
ce qui m'intéresse moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le fait qu'on soit
capable de faire reculer ce projet
vous attendez quoi vous du débat là qui
va s'ouvrir au Sénat est-ce qu'il y a
des avancées par exemple qui pourrait
avoir le jour sur le plan social j'ai
cru comprendre que nous il y a
suffisamment socialiste il y a des
amendements communistes
n'a pas une majorité alors pas du peste
pour vous faire plaisir socialiste
communiste écologiste il y a pas une
majorité les majorité droite j'ai
entendu monsieur Retailleau même les
mesures sur les sur les carrières
longues même ça apparemment ça
contrairement à ce que demandait les
républicains l'assemblée qui fait que
eux sont aussi divisés ce qui peut être
gênant pour le gouvernement parce que
c'est leur principal allié potentiel
pour faire passer le projet de réforme
et bien même monsieur Retailleau pense
que l'histoire du 43 44 années vous
savez faire un père mais on connaît tout
ça ça va peut-être un peu trop loin donc
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est dans le
bon sens sur les femmes comme le disait
Elisabeth est-ce qu'il y a des avancées
à attendre il voudrait faire entrer en
ligne de compte les congés maternité
soit une surcote de 5% soit partir à 63
ans déjà j'allais dire que toutes les
femmes toutes les femmes n'ont pas selon
les mères de famille sont concernés par
les inégalités devant sur le marché de
l'emploi d'accord donc moi je préférais
que on ait une vraie loi pour l'égalité
salariale homme femme comme ça se fait
en Islande qui rapporterait 8 milliards
de cotisations et je profite je
préférerais surtout qu'on arrête au fur
et à mesure de se rendre compte d'une
loi est tellement injuste qu'on est
obligé de prendre bout par bout et de
faire en sorte de dire quand même on va
on va pas aller jusqu'à là pour
certaines catégories de la population et
que on arrête avec ça et qu'on fasse en
sorte que les gens soient pas obligés de
travailler deux ans de plus les femmes
comprises ça serait à mon avis un
progrès plus important les républicains
souhaitaient accélérer les régimes
spéciaux dans cette réforme des
retraites est-ce que ça finalement c'est
pas une mesure de justice est-ce que
vous devriez pas la défendre vous qui
avez combattu la fin des régimes
spéciaux dans la mesure où il y a la
clause du grand-père qui va entrer en
vigueur donc il faudra les nouveaux
entrants envers on s'appliquer la
réforme alors que pour les autres
finalement c'est la génération 61 c'est
demain pour les autres je me réforme de
justice moi
c'est les régimes pionniers qui ont été
gagné avec des conventions collectives
et qui reconnaissaient des spécificités
ou pénibilité du travail
alors si maintenant on pense par exemple
qui est aujourd'hui conducteur de bus
avec les conditions qui sont celles que
l'on subit dans les zones urbaines ou
conducteurs de métro n'est pas pénible
et bien moi je ne suis pas d'accord et
si on me dit c'est injuste vous défendez
tous les régimes spéciaux alors il y a
des différences il y a des régimes
spéciaux qui sont spéciaux parce qu'il y
a une pénibilité au travail qui fait que
il serait logique effectivement qu'il
part plus tôt et j'allais dire que ça
donne à mon avis le problème c'est qu'il
y en a plutôt pas assez plutôt que trop
c'est à dire que je pense que par
exemple pour reprendre la question des
transports de bus ça devrait pas
seulement être réservé au conducteurs de
la RATP ça devrait être étendu à toutes
ces professions c'est un exemple et du
coup on retrouverait peut-être des
conducteurs de bus parce que ça ça aussi
un lien après vous avez aussi vous savez
des régimes spéciaux alors c'est le cas
des avocats c'est le cas de Banque de
France c'est le cas des notaires qui
sauvent
erreur de ma part sont équilibrés en
tant que tel donc c'est pas c'est pas
quelques c'est pas le même type de
problème et à partir de là je ne vois
pas pourquoi on viendrait perturber
l'équilibre de leur orchestre
votre position elle va se poursuivre
dans la rue vous nous avez parlé de
cette journée du 7 mars déjà l'ensemble
des syndicats de la SNCF appellent à une
grève reconductible est-ce que vous vous
appelez un blocage total du pays à
partir du 7 mars alors déjà moi je suis
responsable politique et je ne suis pas
c'est pas moi qui me met en grève vous
voyez ce que je veux dire la difficulté
de cet engrais donc je peux dire ce qui
me semble être le mieux et le mieux pour
faire en sorte de arrêter ce projet
c'est plusieurs jours de grève
reconductibles voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on peut faire plier le gouvernement
maintenant c'est pas moi qui vais faire
l'appel ça c'est la terre syndicale
c'est c'est
bien évidemment
dans l'action syndicale justement là en
ce moment et ben parce que la dernière
journée et celle du 7 mars il se sera
écoulé plus d'une quinzaine de jours
entre les deux est-ce que ça n'a pas
cassé la dynamique de la marque vous
savez pourquoi parce que pour la
première fois depuis longtemps je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure on a tous les
syndicats réunis et que on a ils ont
fait l'ex ils ont fait l'étude de se
dire que cette fois-ci on va pas vivre
une grève par procuration vous savez les
Grecs par procuation ça avait commencé
en 95 il y a des secteurs qui peuvent se
mettre en grève parce qu'ils ont des
statuts moins compliqué que dans le
privé que ils arrivent plus facilement à
mettre à l'arrêt le pays et ils vont ils
font grève pour tout le monde les gens
soutiennent ils font grève pour tout le
monde je pense que les conditions ça ils
l'ont fait pendant des années et que
cette fois-ci ça sera moins simple que
ça l'a été par contre qu'on observe un
peu partout du fait aussi que certains
syndicats se mettent dans l'action CFDT
numéro un dans le privé par exemple on
sait et bien vous avez des grèves dans
des secteurs qui ne faisaient plus grève
depuis longtemps et l'idée je pense que
de l'interdy syndicale ça a été tout ça
prenne le temps face la jonction c'est
dur de faire grève quand vous perdez un
jour deux jours trois jours de travail
fasse la jonction pour pouvoir justement
concentrer les efforts je pense que
c'est plutôt très bien jouer vous allez
voir que le 7 mars ça va être historique
c'est une grève historique en terme de
nombre en termes de manifestants les
rues et moi je pense que ça va donner
l'impulsion pour les jours à venir et
c'est pour ça que j'ai confiance sur le
fait qu'on arrive à faire reculer le
gouvernement historique c'est quoi c'est
plus de 2 millions de personnes dans la
rue je pense qu'on va on va dépasser
largement les scores des autres
qui
surtout des taux de gregistes très
important ce qui n'était pas le cas pour
les dernières mobilisations
bon j'ai vu aussi que tous les syndicats
maintenant appellent à une grève
reconductive dans la SNCF donc les il
peut y avoir un effet boule de neige et
je moi je vais vous dire je pense que 6
pi est à l'arrêt quelques jours ce
gouvernement sera obligé de reculer de
retirer la réforme c'est ce que je crois
parce que à un moment donné je ne
connais pas dans la cinquième république
sauf un exemple en 2010
un projet de réforme imposé quand vous
avez tout le peuple contre vous 9 actifs
sur 10 7 Français sur 10 plus de 6
Français sur 10 qui soutiennent le fait
y compris de bloquer le pays je pense
qu'à un moment donné un gouvernement il
peut pas tenir parce que c'est aussi la
démocratie sociale qui se manifeste et
en plus quand vous avez un projet aussi
mal foutu excusez-moi l'expression où on
nous annonce 1200 euros 1200 euros pour
toutes les carrières longues puis à la
fin il n'a plus de 13000 bah je pense
qu'au fur et à mesure ça plus peut-être
l'anticonstitution très très bref
plusieurs témoignages de députés
rapportent un usage excessif d'alcool à
la buvette de l'Assemblée est-ce que
vous l'avez constaté
bah écoutez comme je suis pas souvent à
la buvette le soir je ne pas les excès
franchement est-ce que c'est très
différent dans le temps j'en sais rien
enfin je sais pas j'ai l'impression
qu'on connaît des choses c'est un peu
par exemple
des bas des retraites on a l'impression
qu'on vivait quelque chose absolument
terrible qui avait jamais été là je me
demande si c'est pas un peu la même
chose c'est-à-dire je menti il y a pas
des sujets qui montent comme ça un petit
peu alcoolisées qui arrivent après la
pause de 21h30 quoi est-ce que vous
l'avez constaté est-ce que vous avez
est-ce qu'il y a des débats qui du coup
on voit quand ils ont mangé quand ils
rentrent mais je vais d'abord je vous
dénoncerai personne
non est-ce que est-ce qu'elles veulent
faire est-ce qu'elle l'a fait
j'ai aucun élément là dessus car vous
vous êtes pour ce genre de tradition
enfant ça vous choque pas non parce
qu'il y a des degrés de tolérance qui il
y a des deux je vais
justifiez des situations aujourd'hui par
Paris
je ne sais pas si c'est différent d'hier
je dis simplement qu'on a un peu
l'impression qu'on découvre un peu l'eau
tiède à chaque fois bon j'ai
l'impression d'après ce que je lis ce
que j'entends c'est que cette buvette
elle a toujours été très fréquentée
est-ce que maintenant on boit plus que
dans le temps
qui pensent
ne l'est peut-être plus aujourd'hui dans
ce domaine comme dans d'autres merci
beaucoup Brigitte boucher merci
infiniment Vincent roux en direct du
Figaro live bonjour à vous Vincent
où est allé aujourd'hui notre invité
vous le savez c'est une que vous voulez
poser une question sur le salon de
l'agriculture alors vous êtes allés au
salon de l'agriculture bonsoir Éric
Coquerel soit vous pensez sans doute
comme la majorité des lecteurs du Figaro
qui pensent que les politiques ont
raison au salon de l'agriculture quel
est le message que vous allez que vous
avez délivré aux agriculteurs que vous
avez encombré franchement moi je j'ai
écouté surtout quoi j'ai pas été j'ai
pas été comme le chef de l'État 12h
j'avais pas le temps et puis des
agriculteurs j'en vois aussi en dehors
du Salon de l'Agriculture j'étais voir
des syndicats agricoles aussi bien de la
FNSEA que la Confédération paysage les
coopératives agricoles qui m'ont trouvé
le rendez-vous très très intéressant
donc j'ai écouté et en fait je me suis
aperçu une chose c'est que quel que soit
les solutions les préoccupations sur les
mêmes sur tout le monde la question de
l'eau la question des pesticides la
question de la crise que connaît le
secteur bio actuellement la question
aussi alors les uns parlent de
souveraineté alimentaire les autres
parlent de protectionnisme votre
problème d'importation de produits qui
sont cultivés dans des conditions que
nous permettons plus en France et qui
sont apportés donc toutes les questions
du libre-échange et puis aussi le la
chose qui est venue partout c'est-à-dire
les prix de l'alimentaire vous savez 13%
d'augmentation et ça ça ça pénalise la
profession les marches des distributeurs
interrogent voilà j'ai entendu ce qui
m'intéressait je vous réponds tout de
suite c'est que de Life quel que soit
après les solutions ils ont pas les
mêmes solutions on le sait il y a
certains avec qui on est plutôt d'accord
plus que d'autres mais n'empêche les
problématiques étaient les mêmes est-ce
que vous pensez après cette visite
comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a quelques
années que en fait il faudrait pas aller
au salon de l'agriculture il faudrait
plutôt faire une journée de l'écologie
en les deux me semble possible moi vous
savez je suis comme beaucoup de Français
des insoumis avec la ruralité en fait
moi je savais avec qui j'étais
aujourd'hui j'étais avec Mathilde
Guignet vous savez qui c'est Mathilde
d'ignès c'est la première députée
ouvrière agricole qui est jamais eu
voilà et elle est française soumise donc
moi je sens pas cette fois que François
Ruffin la pointée il y a un problème de
représentativité
mais peut-être que ça s'améliore aussi
parce que je remarque une chose c'est
qu'on est j'ai été aujourd'hui avec des
des collègues députés insoumise de la
Sarthe de du Maine-et-Loire etc donc
manifestons sa meilleure et je pense que
c'est pas ça qui nous empêche de
connaître le monde agricole d'ici
intéressé c'est desmago pour un
président de passer 12 heures au salon
vous pouvez me dire non pas du tout
c'est son rôle
je pense qu'il y a un côté communication
je vais vous répondre rapidement je
parlais avec un syndicat tout à l'heure
qui me disait qu'il a préféré que
Emmanuel Macron ça s'est plutôt mieux
d'ailleurs c'est fort de voir les
syndicats agricoles avant d'aller au
salon parce que au salon vous êtes vous
le savez j'ai vu madame borne tout à
l'heure elle était entourée de caméra de
micros c'est pas là très sincèrement où
vous et c'est quand même fait qu'on se
peut j'ai quand même vu merci beaucoup
vin
cent rhume pour notre question
d'actualité et bienvenue Israël
directeur adjoint la rédaction du Figaro
c'est à VOUS bonsoir Elisabeth bonsoir
Éric Coquerel bonsoir j'ai une question
qui me brûle les lèvres depuis très
longtemps il y a 6 ans dans une
interview un magazine
monsieur Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dit le
mouvement de la France insoumise est un
mouvement gazeux qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
je suis exégète des citations de
Jean-Luc ce soir qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que le mouvement
français soumis il y a 6 ans a été créé
pour accompagner une campagne électorale
voilà et donc une campagne électorale
c'est l'action c'est pas une campagne
électorale que vous allez organiser un
mouvement
débattre vous avez un programme ça se
programme avait été défini le meilleur
des entre guillemets démocratique il y a
eu plein de débats on avait rencontré
plein de gens et puis à partir de là
vous mettez en action et gazeux ça veut
dire que vous faites en sorte que
justement tous les gens qui veulent
pouvoir rentrer dans ce mouvement le
fasse il suffisait d'aller dans un
groupe d'actions de prendre et puis
d'avoir des formes de mobilisation qui
peuvent être très différentes les amis
tous les jours d'autres ça peut être
simplement de l'organisation horizontale
en fait cet horizontal et la question
pour vous répondre parce que je sens vos
réponses à venir la question de
l'organisation j'allais dire
démocratique du mouvement c'est normal
ne se prouve pas pendant une campagne
électorale et toute lagageur je te
montre c'est le transformer cette
fois-ci en mouvement politique pérenne
est-ce que c'est pas un handicap
aujourd'hui que Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
reste le chef de votre
formation ne soit pas à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat d'ailleurs
déjà Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est pas un
handicap donc je considère la présence
son absence plutôt écoutez ça a été son
choix je vais vous répondre sincèrement
là en ce moment des fois je me dis que
ça serait bien qu'il soit là ah voilà
parce que j'ai moi je l'ai dit
un certain moment parce que Jean-Luc mon
avis reste notre leader voilà d'un point
de vue théorique d'un point de vue
stratégique etc et que je me dis que
finalement je regarde un peu la bataille
des retraites je pense que ça il aurait
été là je pense que ça aurait été gagné
je pense qu'on aurait gagné en
efficacité et on impact et en
coordination donc je vous réponds mais
son choix je le comprends aussi c'est
qu'à un moment donné vous avez envie
justement de pouvoir faire d'autres
choses par exemple de plus vous
consacrer à l'international de plus vous
consacrer vous le savez vous connaissez
comme moi vous savez que Jean-Luc il
aime bien écrire il aime bien théoriser
il est bien réfléchir à l'époque et
laisser aussi une trace par rapport à ça
donc voilà il a estimé qu'il avait pas
le temps de faire deux bon alors c'est
très intéressant d'abord merci pour
votre sincérité mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est justement on avait
l'impression dans ce débat vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure mais dans ce débat
sur la réforme des retraites que il y
avait pas tout à fait une unité de
réflexion entre lui qui voulait pas
aller à cet article 7 et qui demandait
de retenir à tout prix les débats et
vous alors peut-être pas vous
personnellement mais quelques-uns
d'entre vous ou plusieurs qui
souhaitaient y aller
écoutez il y avait une discussion dans
le groupe c'est c'est partout dans la
presse moi je moi personnellement je
m'exprime jamais sur ce qui se passe
dans le groupe tout ce qui me plaît dans
le groupe mais je ne suis plus jamais
mais puisque sur la presse chacun sait
il y a une discussion le groupe bon sur
quelque chose qui m'apparaît et une
différenciation tactique parce que très
sincèrement à partir du moment où vous
avez tout un groupe quasiment à la
totalité qui est d'accord pour ne pas
aller jusqu'à la fin de l'article 7 et
que le débat c'est de savoir si on le
début ou pas ou éventuellement on vote
l'amendement jusqu'à l'amendement de
suppression pour moi c'est tactique
c'est pas une différence de fond il y a
personne même dans la dupes l'édite
alors personne n'était pour aller
jusqu'à la fin de l'examen de la loi bon
bah moi je trouve ça plutôt 5 dans un
groupe de 75 personnes il y a des débats
et je ne trouve pas inconvenant que
quelqu'un qui a été qui reste notre
leader donne sa position si c'est ça
votre question et il était pas c'était
pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon contre le groupe
hein j'ai lu ça c'est extraordinaire non
mais non il y avait un débat dans le
groupe qui existait Jean-Luc a pris une
position on l'a fait connaître bon voilà
je
mes positions et après ma position
centrale je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
elle avait une partie chou qui m'a dit
oui mais parler de vous mais je le parle
de moi ma position centrale c'est que
moi je trouve que le 47 ans est un vrai
scandale et que il fallait appuyer
appuyer et j'ai regretté je l'ai dit
j'ai dit bon rapport avec le numéro 1
syndicaux je les ai tous rencontré en
tant que la Commission évident mais j'ai
grimpé qu'avec nous ils appuient pas sur
le fait qu'on pouvait dépasser cette
fichue clôture du vendredi minuit ce que
le gouvernement a fait avec d'ailleurs
avec le rassemblement national en lisant
le cadeau de faire cette notion de
censure
à cette heure là c'est ça que je veux
dire et donc on pouvait dépasser moi je
pense qu'on aurait dû moi mon objectif
c'était de dire on peut prolonger ce
débat il faut se prolonger bas rien
n'empêche de ne pas le continuer est-ce
que ça vous fait pas mal de lire dans la
presse ou ailleurs dans les médias que
finalement le grand gagnant de tous
débat là vous venez de prononcer son nom
c'est le rassemblement
je le crois pas alors moi je regarde je
regarde pas seulement les sondages je
regarde les le résultat des élections la
période des des
sur les retraites à commencer avec trois
élections partielles les trois cas le RN
a été battu deux cas la nupes conserve
son son poste de députés en le Nord on
gagne 1 avec France insoumise dans
dans le excusez-moi j'ai un trou de
mémoire mais dans l'ouest de la France
et c'est l'autre côté c'est
Renaissance qui gagne contre Laurane son
lacial donc moi je regarde ces résultats
et je me dis que bah au début de cette
campagne en tout cas le ration nationale
est peut-être pas aussi fort qu'on dit
que c'est plutôt la nups qui avait
marqué des points est-ce que à l'issue
de ce mouvement ça va être différent moi
je serai contre la réforme je serai prêt
à m'engager socialement je verrai pas le
rassemblement national comme un allié
qui a posé 200 amendements seulement
alors là c'est un record de d'essayer
d'expédier au plus vite cette loi et qui
a même fait le cadeau gouvernement de
poser une notion de censure ce qui fait
que le gouvernement a dit ah bah voter
la motion de censure ça sera le résultat
de le piège était grossier donc le ce
point de vue là je suis pas sûr qu'ils
entière ils entirent vraiment avantage
alors dans quelques mois il y a des
élections sénatoriales on sait que la
France insoumise n'est pas présente au
Sénat dans la Haute Assemblée
est-ce que là vous avez bon espoir de
remporter un ou deux sièges sachant que
bah les élections sénatoriales ça se
joue beaucoup quand même dans les zones
rurales où vous êtes pas très bien
implanté je me suis occupé une fois
dessinatorial pour le Parti de Gauche
qui était un peu le l'ancêtre voilà on
va dire je suis assez satisfait depuis
mon occupé c'est très compliqué les
sénateurs donc surtout pour un parti
neuf comme le nôtre un mouvement neuf
donc je ne sais pas très sincèrement
j'ai pas suffisamment étui la chose sur
le papier il y a il y a des possibilités
il y a des endroits où on a si en plus
on arrive à certains départements des
accords avec la nupesse on a des petits
de gains et de gains pour toute la nuit
Pesse y compris France insoumise voilà
j'en sais pas plus très sincèrement
alors vous êtes président de la
commission des finances à l'Assemblée
nationale
ça vous a changé ou pas
non non
ça vous a pas changé même
idéologiquement c'est-à-dire que vous
aviez on vous connaissez pour des
positions sur le plan financier enfin
sur toutes les questions économiques
toujours assez radicales est-ce que le
fait de fréquenter Bruno Le Maire alors
pas lui mais le ministre de l'Économie
le fait d'être finalement un des hommes
les plus importants ou des élus pour pas
les plus importants en la matière
ça vous oblige pas à faire des compromis
avec ce que vous pensez non non je reste
toujours je reste toujours radicalement
opposé au capitalisme financière au
libellé ou libéralisme si c'est ça la
question non toujours de manière mais si
vous avez observé moi je suis plutôt
quelqu'un
j'aime bien argumenté voilà et c'était
le cas quand j'étais député j'avais déjà
des débats parce que j'étais le chef de
fil des de France insoumise avec Bruno
Le Maire bon à partir du moment où j'ai
quelqu'un en face de moi qui aime aussi
argumenter sur le fond c'est ce que je
reconnais à Bruno Le Maire par exemple
ce n'est pas d'accord bah moi j'ai
toujours plaisir à le faire et puis les
ministres avec qui ça se passe moins sur
le front c'est compliqué non ce que ça
m'a donné par contre ça c'est vrai c'est
vous avez à présent heureusement de
commission de des finances ne peut pas
tout on va dire donc vous avez aussi un
rôle d'animer la Commission des cellules
donner le plus de poids possible des
débats intéressants ça oui ça m'a c'est
un nouvel apprentissage et ça c'est
plutôt agréable de l'exécutif
que la France insoumise avec d'autres
avec Alexis Corbière avec Madame Garrido
avec François Ruffin vous n'avez plus
justement l'exécutif de votre parti
politique et
finalement bon je sais que vous n'aimez
pas parler de vous-même mais c'est quand
même un peu étrange cette histoire non
seulement j'aime pas parler moi-même
mais alors j'aime pas non plus vous avez
été très honnête tout à l'heure face à
une question de Yves donc
j'aime pas j'ai pas spécialement voulu
commenter ces questions à terme je dis
réservé à l'interne et alors là il y a
un autre moment où je vais pas les
commenter plus qu'un autre c'est le
moment des référentes des retraites ou
comme je disais tout à l'heure pour moi
laisser des sujets un peu annexes qui
vont faire des grandes pages dans les
journaux sur un tel a dit ça l'autre t'a
dit ça etc alors que ça nécessite
l'unité c'est encore moi le moment où je
vais le faire je vais vous redire je
pense que d'abord je suis je suis dans
le bureau du groupe de l'Assemblée
nationale donc j'ai un poids dans le
groupe quand même
relativement important j'ai finalement
été au Conseil proposé par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour voir comment ça
fonctionnait voir s'il y avait quelque
chose si ça pouvait être une vraie
direction j'ai des remarques à faire je
les ai fait je pense que les choses
pourront évoluer d'ici quelques mois
puisque il y a une revue avec une autre
assemblée représentative sur le
fonctionnement sur la question des votes
et autres donc je ne prononce pas ça
mais franchement j'ai pas envie d'en
faire un débat alors
peut-être que contrairement à Alexis le
fait d'être président de la commission
des finances et avoir un rôle de toute
façon fait que je vais peut-être vécu de
manière moins compliquée que la sienne
alors j'ai quand même une question et
dernière question de répondre c'est que
il y a une élection présidentielle tout
le monde le sait d'ici à 4 ans en 2027
si vous deviez choisir entre François
Ruffin et Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous
choisiriez qui vous croyez vraiment je
vais vous répondre à ça ben je sais pas
non 2020
groupe bon d'abord
mener cette cette mission ensemble après
les insultes vous allez encore me dire
c'est pas très grave etc il y a aucun
non non entre groupes bien sûr dans
l'hémicycle à l'occasion de la réforme
des retraites bon ça ça n'a pas
d'importance on efface tout et on
travaille en commun oui je pense oui
alors déjà en commun ça veut pas dire
qu'on va arriver au qu'ils ont commune
d'accord mais oui alors déjà c'est un
peu le prof de la commission des
finances pour quiconque la connaît il y
a une atmosphère moi j'ai souhaité la
perpétuer je l'ai connu avec Éric verse
j'ai souhaité la continuer et
deuxièmement c'est moi qui ai voulu
instituer le fait que dans toute mission
d'information vous aviez forcément à
binôme de quelqu'un de la majorité de
l'opposition ou vice faire ça quelqu'un
de l'opposition et de la majorité voilà
pour essayer
de façon j'ai voulu l'installer d'accord
pour pouvoir faire en sorte rayançon il
n'y a pas très longtemps c'était il y a
deux ans j'ai fait une mission
d'information avec Monsieur Mathy du
modem sur la question de l'impôt
différentiel c'est-à-dire vous savez
quand vous payez moins d'impôts à
l'étranger de savoir si certains
partaient pas parce qu'ils profitaient
de paradis fiscaux et finalement on est
arrivé quasiment au même préconisations
alors je dis pas qu'on va y arriver que
j'en renie Cazeneuve parce que le sujet
là me paraît plus compliqué mais en tout
cas je pense qu'on peut avoir des
auditions intéressantes on peut avoir
ici d'avoir un état des lieux communs
pourquoi pas et puis après on aura
sûrement des préconisations différentes
et en tout cas ce sera intéressant parce
que comme vous stigmatisez souvent la
sous-imposition des grandes entreprises
vous allez faire le clair entre ce degré
d'imposition par rapport aux petites
entreprises on attend les résultats
vous allez le vérifier bonsoir Violetta
merci beaucoup de nous avoir rejoint
vous êtes députés Renaissance et
évidemment votre premier sujet de débat
avec Éric Coquerel de la retraite on
imagine oui merci j'aimerais revenir sur
les propos que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure monsieur le Président vous avez
évoqué avec une certaine forme de
fatalisme la violence dans les débats à
l'Assemblée nationale moi qui suis
nouvellement député j'ai plutôt constaté
que l'obstruction le nombre les milliers
commandement déposé en partie par votre
groupe et puis les moments de violence
qui qui ont animé les débats ont fait
que on s'est arrêté le dernier jour du
débat programmé très très loin de
l'article 7 et aujourd'hui la réforme
des retraites elle va être examinée au
Sénat avec on l'espère peut-être un vrai
débat de fond comme vous l'aimez avec
les arguments sur l'article 7 et donc ma
question c'est est-ce que en tant que
président de la commission des finances
en tant que élu expérimenté vous n'avez
pas des regrets sur la façon dont ces 15
jours se sont passés à l'Assemblée
profond c'est que vous et votre majorité
majorité en tout cas la minorité
présidentielle vous ayez utilisé un
outil Parlement législatif qui ne
correspond pas du tout à une loi de
cette ampleur qui vous permet d'arrêter
les débats quand vous le souhaitez parce
que vous aurez plus les propos loger et
le même de le faire sans vote c'est ça
qui me paraît le plus grand scandale
démocratique
vis-à-vis du Parlement et vis-à-vis
j'aille bien même d'un mépris du
Parlement voilà ma réponse oui après
vous vous exprimez quand même dans toute
cette soirée de débats un souhait de
respecter institution de la représenter
de permettre des missions avec des
personnes de l'opposition et donc à un
moment quand ce format est décidé de 50
jours avec une partie à l'Assemblée une
partie au Sénat moi je me dis vous
auriez pu avoir le choix aussi de de
retirer un certain nombre d'amendements
je sais qu'il y a eu des débats à
l'intérieur de la nups sur ce sujet là
des collègues de votre groupe en ont
d'ailleurs retiré de façon massive on
aurait pu avancer sur au-delà des
seniors au-delà des régimes spéciaux sur
le sujet de des femmes sur le sujet des
retraites minimum sur le sujet de l'âge
sur le sujet du modèle économique du
financement de nos retraites pour pour
nos générations futures et tout ça en
fait ça a été balayé avec des moments
extrêmement enfin moi j'ai moi j'ai été
extrêmement choqué de certains moments
quand on traite le ministre Olivier du
somme d'assassin je crois pas que ce
soit les méthodes que vous vous
préconisez
que mon collègue qu'il a qui s'est
exprimé comme ça s'est excusé c'est
quand même suffisamment rare vous savez
que vous savez ça s'entend peut-être
moins voilà mais vous savez ça sentait à
côté de la du côté de Renaissance on
entend des choses pas non plus très
agréables venant de l'assemblée
de notre côté
certaines comparaison qui ont été faites
qui semblaient alors c'était moderne
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence enfin bon
donc non moi je vous dis je pense que
tous ces durci du fait même du du type
de de choisir et il nous a été imposé il
est d'ailleurs même quelque part je vais
vous dire je vais vous dire j'ai un
collègue vous êtes comme moi député vous
ne pouvez pas vous ne pouvez pas vous
satisfaire d'un Parlement ou pour passer
le budget qui est votre prérogative
numéro 1 comme la mienne d'accord on
fait 10 49-3 pour imposer le budget et
surtout on revient par exemple sur tel
ou tel article avait été modifié par
l'opposition sur les DOM-TOM sur les sur
la rénovation thermique vous ne pouvez
pas vous satisfaire du fait que par
exemple le gouvernement décide grâce à
cet outil parlementaire là je parle des
retraites de dire l'article 2 n'a pas
été adopté c'est pas grave on le remet
tel quel pour le Sénat en tant que
parlementaire vous ne pouvez pas pas
accepter ça et moi je vais vous dire je
vais vous dire mon problème de fond j'ai
rencontré quelques jours après mais mes
collègues de la commission des finances
islandaises bien et ben en Islande ils
connaissent pas le 49-3 ils connais pas
le 47 ans et je pense que c'est
nettement préférable en terme de
jusqu'au bout le gouvernement était
obligé de le présenter dans ces
termes-là au Sénat c'est l'absence de
vote
il faut pas le gouvernement savait
qu'avec 9 jours seulement puisque il y a
eu un refus de l'Assemblée d'ouvrir le
week-end comme on le demandait plus le
jeudi je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure la
niche socialiste qui a été enlevée le
gouvernement savait de toute façon qu'on
ne pouvait pas on aurait pu enlever la
moitié nous avons mis on ne pouvait pas
arriver jusqu'à la fin donc il me
servait d'ailleurs à mon avis il
souhaitait pas spécialement
vous vous oubliez une chose vous parlez
de minorité moi je vais vous parler de
majorité relative c'est qu'effectivement
on est dans une configuration qui est
très différente à l'Assemblée nationale
qui est beaucoup plus représentatif de
l'ensemble des voix des Français mais
c'est quand même une majorité relative
que nous nous devons pour porter un
projet et surtout pour être responsable
du budget de la France et quand on
entend le programme de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le programme financier vous
qui êtes président de la commission des
finances avec un programme présidentiel
qui est complètement infinementable avec
des retraites à 60 ans qui amènent des
déficits en milliards d'euros nous un
moment c'est clair que il y a une
responsabilité à prendre avec les outils
qui existent dans l'institution pour
faire en sorte que on est un système en
équilibre pour les retraites
de fond mais vous savez très bien que
c'est très forme de n'est pas faite pour
résorber un déficit qui au maximum est
estimé à 3% de ce que coûte les
retraites c'est-à-dire beaucoup moins
que le déficit de l'État d'accord et
encore en prenant les chiffres de 12
milliards
de l'état où c'est très bien que c'est
pas fait pour ça puisque le corps l'a
dit d'accord moi j'ai auditionné le
prénom du corps j'étais très heureux
qu'il le dise il a expliqué que la
question des retraites c'était pas
qu'elles allaient coûter plus cher à la
nation dans les années à venir en
pourcentage du c'est le problème des
ressources et bien vous me posez la
question que ce soit pour les retraites
actuelles ou même effectivement pour
passer à la retraite à 60 ans avec 40
annuités qui coûterait 55 milliards oui
je vous donne les chiffres et bien nous
avons des propositions je vous en donner
deux l'égalité salariale hommes femmes
et ça rapporte ça rapportait 5 milliards
de retour tout de suite
et 8 milliards à long terme vous décidez
par exemple non pas d'un fiscaliser mais
de faire une cotisation sur les
dividendes actuels de 10% même pas les
cotisations du travail c'est 17%, ça
vous rapporterait 25 milliards d'euros
donc des financements
c'est le programme de la France
insoumise mais c'est marrant parce que
ça vous dérange pas de faire cotiser les
salariés deux ans de plus en les
obligeant à travailler plus ça ça vous
dérange pas ça c'est pas ça c'est
de réduire l'attractivité
entre les générations et les solidarité
d'un système
évident du CAC 40 qui sont quand même
l'utilisation de la rendre capitaliste
la pire qui soit puisqu'elle est même
pas pour investir l'économie c'est une
rang que les les gens prennent pour eux
que c'est des records ça à un moment
donné on parle de faire une cotisation
là-dessus vous trouvez ça scandaleux
même ça rapporterait plus d'un milliard
par contre de forcer les gens à
travailler deux secondes de plus donc
deux ans de plus de cotisation là ça
vous pose pas de problème c'est quand
même un autre sujet d'interpellation oui
on commence cette semaine l'examen du
projet de loi nucléaire sur
l'accélération du nucléaire même si je
ne suis pas de partie de la commission
qui va l'examiner je serai présente dans
les débats qui seront autour de la
mi-mars et l'objectif de ce projet de
loi c'est d'accélérer la construction du
nucléaire de faciliter sur le plan
administratif aussi l'ensemble des
démarches pour qu'on aille plus vite
pourquoi parce que le Président de la
République l'a annoncé il y a un an on
souhaite vraiment être le premier pays
qui est une énergie décarbonée qui
n'utilise plus et de moins en moins à
l'énergie fossile et on va construire
six nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires moi
j'ai échangé avec des personnalités de
votre groupe de la nups notamment votre
votre collègue monsieur jumelle du Parti
communiste qui lui m'indique assez
naturellement parce qu'il connaît le
bien le sujet parce qu'il connaît les
emplois qu'il y a derrière parce qu'il
connaît l'urgence d'avoir une énergie
décarbonée en France et de pouvoir
produire pour plus d'électricité pour
tous les usages que nous que nous
modifions et bien on sent que le Parti
communiste lui va plutôt s'associer et
voter pour cette loi et que vous à LFI
vous prenez l'inverse donc ma question
elle est plutôt comment aujourd'hui vous
aborder ce débat sur le nucléaire alors
que nous on souhaite vraiment là aussi
prendre des responsabilités en urgence
et elle est très vite en simplifiant et
ben justement est-ce que vous allez nous
suivre là-dessus je vais vous répondre
je pense que justement il faut pas les
prendre en urgence parce que le problème
qu'on a là que ça soit pour l'examen de
la loi sur le renouvelable ou sur le
nucléaire maintenant c'est qu'on fait ça
à l'envers c'est à dire au lieu
d'étudier ça après la prochaine loi de
programmation qui va déterminer les
pourcentages de tel ou tel énergie on
commence si vous voulez par les outils
ce qui est un peu curieux parce que au
lieu de se fixer ce métier bon déjà ma
première réponse c'est qu'on devrait se
donner le temps deuxième réponse je vais
vous dire c'est que tout ça devrait et
ça fait longtemps faire partie d'un vrai
débat public parce que vous me donnez
des arguments et j'en discutent
d'ailleurs avec mon camarade jumelles
que j'apprécie beaucoup sur le nucléaire
mais vous savez très bien comme moi que
des arguments contre le nucléaire je
peux vous en donner d'autant que je peux
vous dire que les deux
chez les deux scénarios qui ont été
retenus à un moment donné au niveau
électricité de 100% renouvelable sont
des scénarios qui tiennent le coup y
compris financièrement vous avez prôné
la sortie complète du nucléaire tout
votre programme présidentiel c'est même
pas entre deux
nucléaire oui bien sûr moi je pense que
ce n'est pas une énergie d'avenir parce
que je considère plusieurs problèmes
d'abord elle elle pose un problème
d'autonomie on n'a pas d'uranium en
France je vous le rappelle et que par
exemple certains pays qui ont de
l'uranium pose aujourd'hui
éventuellement des problèmes
géostratégiques ou un problème
d'exploitation de ces pays pour
l'uranium deuxièmement parce que on sait
toujours pas quoi faire des déchets et
troisièmement parce que il vous a pas
échappé c'est juste un sujet
qu'aujourd'hui le problème de l'eau
devient un problème crucial et il y a
une énergie qui est véritablement
mobilisatrice en terme d'eau c'est le
nucléaire donc moi je pense que ça là on
va parler le temps de débattre dans le
fond mais en plus avec les surcoulent le
père de flamonville 19 milliards au lieu
des 3 milliards au départ penser qu'on
va faire une accélération de la
construction de pairs comme avenir pour
l'énergie en France me semble me semble
il me semble qu'on devrait avoir un
débat public comme on l'a eu contre le
nucléaire mais vous avez aussi voté
contre le projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables moi j'ai envie de
comprendre un moment parce que sur les
énergies on est d'accord que il faut
accélérer là aussi c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec le projet de loi on est bien sur un
objectif de 55 ans notre objectif c'est
vraiment le maximum d'énergie décarbonée
mais avec votre votre programme à 100%
d'énergie renouvelable vous savez bien
que c'est des choses qui n'ont jamais
été faites en Europe donc il y a et puis
c'est des énergies qui ne sont pas
fiables dans le temps sur la capacité à
couvrir l'ensemble des besoins en
électricité en France parce qu'on est le
seul pays à ne pas avoir atteint nos
objectifs en termes d'énergie
renouvelables donc vous votez non à
toutes les lois sur l'énergie donc je
vais vous répondre on devrait être à 19%
quoi des 23% ou de devrions être
actuellement en termes d'investissement
c'est pas vrai de dire qu'on va faire un
investissement sur le nucléaire on
commence par 6 opermes il en premier
d'autres et puis en même temps aller
chercher l'argent nécessaire à l'énergie
renouvelable en termes de recherche je
pense ça va être très compliqué de faire
les deux et troisièmement pourquoi nous
étions parce que nous ce que nous avons
dit c'est qu'il y avait quasiment rien
dans cette voie sur le renouvelable
notamment on parlait de planification
écologique en termes de contraintes et
tout ça il devait quasiment rien bien je
connais bien le problème de la pour y
avoir travaillé donc il y avait vraiment
pas grand chose qui a améliorait la
situation par contre ce qu'on s’aperçoit
c'est que là pour le nucléaire là vous
allez effectivement alléger toutes les
conditions administratives moi je crois
qu'en réalité votre loi sur le génère
c'était un prétexte pour préparer celles
sur le nucléaire qui elle par contre est
une un véritable plus pour l'énergie
nucléaire donc voilà la raison pour
lesquelles on n'a pas voté pour un
leurre mais du coup on est sur une
politique énergétique où nous ce qu'on
souhaite c'est vraiment d'abord
moderniser des équipements qui sont
vieillissants vous le savez on a une
grande partie de nos réacteurs de nos 50
irréacteurs nucléaires qui qui seront
obsolètes à horizon 2060 donc vous dites
on peut prendre le temps mais moi je
considère plutôt qu'il y a urgence y
compris moderniser l'ensemble des
équipements d'avoir cette sécurité aussi
des équipements nucléaires dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure et puis la
deuxième chose c'est que on a des
consommations électriques des
transformations de notre fonctionnement
dans les villes je pense aux voitures
électriques à l'industrie qui va devoir
s'électrifier aussi pour consommer moins
d'énergie fossiles de gaz et et de
charbon mais tout ça à un moment on sait
bien que c'est pas avec le rythme des
éoliennes les éoliennes en mer ou les
endroits comme dans ma région
Hauts-de-France où il y a déjà beaucoup
d'éoliennes sur les les dans les champs
et dans les campagnes on sait qu'on ne
pleure pas assez vite deux petites
choses
alors donc c'est RTE qui a fait quand
même les rapports donc qui existe tout
ce qu'on a besoin d'une augmentation
très forte de la consommation d'énergie
électrique
y compris et moi je préfère alors il
faut je vais regarder un peu dans le
détail ce qui est dedans et où l'État
met parce qu'ils sont que l'étape n'est
pas beaucoup mais je préfère qu'on
investisse 100 milliards sur le à un
moment donné sur le ferroviaire plutôt
que de penser où tout électrique des
voitures qui vont consommer je pense
qu'il faut faire les deux je pense que
ça va être un plus compliqué de faire
les deux mais surtout je vais vous
répondre si justement vous voulez
préparer la suite vous commencez pas à
démonter l'IRSN qui est l'Institut de
radioprotection le secret d'une claire
qui manifeste demain et que nous
soutenons parce que là un vrai problème
de faire en sorte que l'expertise
indépendante ne puisse plus être
dissocier du contrôle que joue la SN
vous avez bien vu qu'en France on meurt
d'avoir des milliers 1200 agences
publics avec des
experts de l'IRL et donc dans la fusion
de plusieurs agences nationales tout en
garantissant l'indépendance la
transparence moi je pense que c'est une
bonne du gel est en train de juger
là-dessus parce que dans un sujet comme
nucléaire on ne prend pas de risque et
avoir une institution indépendante de
celle qui a qui agit qui est la SN qui
était très bien je crois que c'est
vraiment nécessaire merci c'était
passionnant merci de vous d'avoir été
avec nous un dernier
rendez-vous avec Vincent roux en direct
du Figaro live cher Vincent c'est à vous
oui on va parler un peu du crâne et
puisque
vendredi dernier a marqué le premier
anniversaire de
l'intervention russe de l'agression
russe en Ukraine est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord Éric Coquerel avec cette
déclaration de Raphaël Glucksmann la
défaite de Poutine est essentielle pour
la sécurité des Européens moi ce que je
pense c'est que l'Ukraine ne doit pas
perdre voilà donc ça veut dire une chose
c'est que l'agresseur qui Poutine doit
se retirer de l'Ukraine où il est rentré
en violation du droit international
voilà ce qui me paraît non mais j'ai
compris je vous réponds la différence
elle est elle est là c'est à dire que
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui on a un
objectif que la Russie sort de l'Ukraine
voilà l'objectif doit être atteignant
je lisais je lisais un philosophe
allemand dans les pages du virus c'était
le monde c'était pas à votre journal
mais
à bermas qui est quand même quelqu'un
voilà qui faisait la différence entre le
fait de d'aider l'Ukraine à ne pas
perdre la guerre et la question de la
victoire sur Poutine et la différence
peut-être c'est justement le moment où
vous pouvez plus aller vers des
situations négociations et ou en termes
d'armement vous pouvez rentrer dans une
spirale qui contrairement à certains
nous entraînerait sur une troisième
guerre mondiale je dis contrairement à
ce matin est-ce que certains s'amusent à
penser qu'on est dans une troisième
guerre mondiale je pense que c'est de ne
pas connaître les deux programmes
mondiales de dire des choses comme ça
donc il faut arriver à tenir les deux
bouts et ça passe par rechercher quand
même à la fois de soutenir l'Ukraine et
à la fois de sortir de trouver une
studio négocié alors Glucksman est un
certain nombre d'intellectuels de
leaders de gauche à Marine tantelier
Olivier Faure
ont signé une tribune avec une centaine
d'intellectuels précisément dans le
monde la semaine dernière où ils
appellent à soutenir et amplifier l'aide
militaire française à l'Ukraine
en disant que ça relève du combat Ant
qui fut l'honneur de son histoire est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut
augmenter l'aide militaire française et
européenne et bien je pense qu'il faut
en rester à certaines limites qui
permettent à l'Ukraine de ne pas perdre
la guerre mais aussi qui nous entrent
pas dans un conflit dans un conflit
mondial
pour vous aussi parce que je veux dire
on parle entre puissance qui ont qui ont
l'arme atomique on n'est pas et avec en
plus monsieur Poutine à la tête d'une
séquence donc il faut le contraindre il
faut le contraindre à des négociations
et moi je vous donne une chose je sais
je connais la ce que je voudrais surtout
ce que je voudrais surtout c'est qu'on
dise débat à l'Assemblée nationale voilà
ce que je crois très important par
rapport à quelque chose c'est c'est ça
qui devrait tous nous rejoindre à voir
ce débat à l'Assemblée nationale merci
vous aussi Violetta vous dites il faut
un débat sur évidemment le crâne et les
moyens
son vote et qui se passe
avec votre voilà c'est le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup Vincent roux merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
cet exercice du débat merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis à la semaine prochaine
mais au même endroit comment on dit
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]